[Music]
oh my god
that is nasty what a sick move
bishop takes c2 takes b3
that was the point everybody is queen a1
mate was threatened sorry robert guide
no that was so sick that was so sick
here he's gotta convert and then we'll
back up and show that tactic but the uh
that was that was a very very nice
finish there
oh and this is only 25 moves in and
white's just getting pummeled
yeah you can even got to take a2 first
and then you're threading to check on
the c
file this should just be
clean man
what a shot with knight what is
happening here
jack you take b2 it's over wow
now now parham's laughing he might as
well have just been like
like dude dude
dude you couldn't have let me get one
dude
and now magnus is even demonstrating wow
he's demonstrating the
corresponding squares of king
wait a second i'm not sure magnus should
have done that though yeah wait don't go
too far
wait oh
now they're just dancing like a couple
of fools
right oh man
parham is laughing because magnus there
voluntarily went into a pawn ending with
a pawn
down but i gotta like white here as
black is congested
and now the king to g7 interrupting the
play
where's that king going i think he just
needed to make a move and here
he goes queen to c3 and queen c7 and now
they're flying
i'm not sure anybody's winning here rook
siete is
the king is on a six what
rook c8 come on now this is not real
no way you're surviving this position
can you be queen c7
a trade i think they're just blitzing
now they're not sure what's happening
at all what's this oh my gosh here comes
the king
this is good g4 is a bad move g4 was
definitely a bad move it did
not it was not correct but you know what
right around now it doesn't matter what
correct
is because they're just blitzing two
seconds left three seconds both sides
just
go just going down with no time on the
clock
it's winning for black though knight g3
knight takes e4 he just win the pawn
directly it's
a very good uh king walk oh it's a draw
oh my god it's some kind of a caspar of
game you know this guy's powerful
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
evergreen and stuff 12 seconds
you cannot defend this with black in
this time it's just for sure just
somehow wins this game
what is he doing what is it why did he
allow the king back in king was like
i have no idea what's going on 36
seconds man 36 seconds he needs to just
drag it out and not lose
oh he's actually losing control of the
position he's losing he's losing his
queen
and he's he's in time he's also in time
he doesn't does he know yesterday
oh my god oh my epic epic
epic
this is brilliant this is insane
the players have to rematch let's go
here we go
okay but this should be a hole three
pawns through he barely got that move
off
oh my god oh wait was was there a win
there a check and a trade on a7
oh oh my god he's just winning now what
he trades and wins the pawn and sauron
is gonna be down
three games headed into bullet
what a heartbreaker to bring the five
minute to a close let's
just take a quick peek at that like you
said this should have been a draw
even just back to this moment here but
f3
which is so heartbreaking it's the
natural move to play right f3 is like
i've got my rook behind the pawn for a
reason here everybody let's dance
but f3 actually trades into the lost
king and pawn ending
the pawn loses its protection and with
it
sauron loses the game oh wait the ropes
trap itself
oh hey car laughs the car's laughing
he's like
how did that happen he's like oops
rook h4 g5
wow that looks so happy look at this
yeah that's an awkward move to miss
and now bishop f7 hikaru gives the nod
of i don't think so now you're allowing
knight d5
yeah and knight f5 is getting out wait
knight f740
oh my gosh the car goes down
oh my gosh yeah the knight f6 queen
takes f6 and
was that king upon any winnie
oh my god multiple wins missed
because he takes f2 as me
wait what is happening here who's gonna
win queen d5 check
and is and blacks winning levon is up a
pawn
check looks like uh oh wait
what why did he do this he blundered
wesley blundered in one move
oh my god he just resigned that was
unbelievable
he had two let's back up he had two and
a half minutes so wesley just
just miscalculates i mean
he still could have just played 97 and
sat tight he's still totally winning
but he just yes forgets that the uh the
rook and can take and i don't have to do
anything else for my back rank i'm just
winning the
shade wow that is it turn around what an
extraordinary turnaround what really
just
cut that rook off which makes a4 more
tempting as well because now you play a4
and then push up on the b5 yeah here
comes the king so this is my first
instinct and looks like he's going to
end up with two passers on the on the
queen side now if you take the king
takes everybody and the rook
remains defending the a pawn i think
he's winning
wow that would be quite the conversion
for sauron
to to level the score in this match here
about 40 whoa and nvl just throws in the
towel
says good play sir is good
and then knight comes in yeah e3 yeah
that's also nice and g4
uh oh the meeting that is on for perugia
yeah one minute up one night if i need
to find it and then rook d1
wait all he needs is a draw but it's
hard to
force it i know but here comes the
people
oh my god no bishop by six is good you
should play six this should be five
oh okay this is checklisted to check
knight to check
your check and you win three oh he
didn't see it natalie check was there
oh but he's found he's found nine of
three no but bishop to six and now
another three rookie two
no bishop takes f3 then i mean you
doesn't help oh my god rouge is going to
send it over time
no he's going to win it he's going to
win it yeah he wins it he wins it
oh god this is insane man this is insane
this is insane yeah that's still still
tonight what an incredible
heartbreak i have never seen a match
come down to this kind of
[Music]